One of the things you said about the
shadow,
and this is I would say one of the
primary impediments to enlightenment is
that if you start looking at your
motives for,
for misbehaving,
and,
and I mean by that,
something very specific.
I mean,
I don't mean that you're misbehaving by
someone else's standards.
I don't mean that.
I mean when you know by your own
standards that you're doing something
that's devious or malevolent or
underhanded,
you know it and you still do it.
So it's your own judgment you're
bringing to bear on yourself.
If you look at why you're doing that,
the longer you look at it,
the deeper a hole you dig.
And so this is the Motif of Dante's
inferno fundamentally.
So Dante's inferno is a story about,
um,
I can't remember his name unfortunately,
might be Dante,
in fact,
although I don't remember.
He's led into hell by Virgil,
who's an,
who's an ancient,
who is an ancient philosopher,
thinker and hell has levels.
And so the outer level is,
and this is a Christianized version of
hell because there's hills of all sorts,
but this is a christianized virgin
version.
And so the on the outermost levels of
hell,
which is sort of like normal life,
are the ancient philosophers,
so they're still in hell because they
weren't Christian,
but it's kind of like,
it's like cheap motel hell instead of
the full pip thing,
you know?
And so then Dante goes deeper and deeper
into hell until he gets right to the
bottom of it.
It's been a while since I read it,
but if I remember correctly,
Satan himself is encased in ice at the
bottom of hell,
surrounded by people who betray others.
And so Dante,
his notion was that the worst of all
possible violations of moral behavior
was be trail and that they're in the
deepest levels of hell.
And I really liked that idea.
I think it's true because if you trust
me,
then you're manifesting the necessary
courage that put someone through life.
You know,
if you're smart,
you don't trust because you're naive.
You Trust me knowing that I've full of
snakes and so are you.
But maybe we could cooperate and move
things along nicely.
We know and we could reduce each other
to the word to our word.
And we could cooperate,
but you're awake,
you know,
and then I'd be trey that then I'm
undermining your necessary faith in life
and humanity and you can really hurt
someone that way.
Like sometimes it's self be trail,
but you can really do someone in that.
We can really traumatize them,
they can so that they can't recover.
And so it's a really terrible thing to
do to someone and maybe it's the worst
thing and that was don taste idea and
it's tied in.
That makes very interesting reading.
If you read it at the same time as
Milton's paradise lost because those are
metaphysical explorations.
This is what they are.
They're metaphysical explorations of the
terrible places you can end up and that
people do end up and also a metaphysical
explanation of what spirit takes you
there.
So because you might ask,
well why'd you betray someone?
And that is a deep question and so
you'll have your specific reasons.
But under that there'll be some other
reasons.
And under that there'll be some other
And if you go all the way to the bottom,
you come up with the ultimate reasons
why you'd be trade someone and when you
look at that,
that will not be pretty.
That's when your proclivity for evil,
let's say you nights with the general
human proclivity for evil and you
discover just exactly what you're
capable of.
And so humans notion was that,
well that was a full encounter with the
shadow,
which is I suppose partly what this
course is about because one of the
things that I believe I told you at the
beginning was that I was going to try to
help you understand how it might be that
you could be an Auschwitz guard and to
really understand that that's a
horrifying thing to understand.
But I'll tell you,
if you want to grow some teeth,
that's a really good thing to
understand.
So we were talking about your capacity
to negotiate before,
like if you aren't a monster,
you cannot negotiate.
But if you,
if you've got that under control,
then you don't have to be a monster.
It's really paradoxical.
So if you're just naive,
well you end up in jail.
And marionette master has control over
you.
That's not helpful.
So that's not good.
That just means you're useless and you
can be manipulated,
won't go out of your way to be
malevolent.
But it's mostly because you just don't
have the skills or the organizational
skills or,
or even the depth to do that.
You know you're good because you're
harmless.
That's not good.
That's easily manipulated.
And so you think,
well how do you get out of that?
Well,
partly you watch people that because you
know what they're like because you know
what you're like and that,
but you also know what you could do and
would do if you were pushed.
And so you don't have to show much of
that when you're negotiating with
someone for them to take you really
seriously.
So it's a strange thing,
you know,
but one of the things you pointed out
too was that what you most need to know
will be found where you least want to
look.
And that's because you haven't already
looked there.
And so it's a little different for every
everyone,
right?
Because your particular place you'd want
to look isn't going to be the same as
your place,
but you're going to have a place you
don't want to look and what you haven't
discovered.
That's where it is,
and so that's partly going to be
discovered by you looking at what you're
capable of,
what you're truly capable of.